when do you think
would be uh a moment
like a singularity moment for the
metaverse where
there's a lot of ways to ask this
question but you know
people will have
many or most of their meaningful
experiences in the metaverse versus the
real world and actually it's interesting
to think about the fact that a lot of
people are having
the most important moments of their life
happen in the digital sphere especially
not jenkovid
you know like even falling in love or
meeting friends or getting excited about
stuff that is happening on the 2d
digital plane when do you think the
metaverse will provide those experiences
for a large number like a yeah i think
it's a really popular good question
there was
someone you know i read this piece that
framed this says
a lot of people think that the metaverse
is about a place
but
one definition of this is it's about
a time when basically immersive digital
worlds become the primary way that we
that we live our lives and spend our
time um i think that's a reasonable
construct and from that perspective you
know i think um
you you also just want to look at this
as a continuation because it's not like
okay we are building digital worlds but
we don't have that today i think you
know you know you and i probably already
live a very large part of our life in
digital worlds they're just not 3d
immersive virtual reality but you know i
do a lot of meetings over video or i
spend a lot of time writing things over
email or whatsapp or or whatever so what
is it going to take to get there for
kind of the immersive presence version
of this which i think is what you're
asking um and for that i think that
there's just a bunch of different use
cases
and and um
you know i think when you're when you're
building
technology i think
you're
a lot of it is just you're managing this
duality where on the one hand you want
to build these elegant things that can
scale and you know have billions of
people use them and get value from them
and then on the other hand you're
fighting this kind of ground game where
it's just there are just a lot of
different use cases and people do
different things and like you want to be
able to unlock them so the first ones
that we basically went after
were gaming
with quest
and social experiences and this is you
know it goes back to when we started
working on virtual reality my my theory
at the time was basically
people thought about it as gaming
but
if you look at all computing platforms
up to that point um you know gaming is a
huge part it was a huge part of pcs it
was a huge part of mobile
but it was also very
decentralized right there wasn't you
know for the most part you know one or
two gaming companies there were a lot of
gaming companies and gaming is somewhat
hits based i mean we're getting some
games that are that have more longevity
but um but but in general you know there
were a lot of a lot of different games
out there
but on pc and
um
and on mobile
the companies that focused on
communication and social interaction
there tended to be a smaller number of
those and that ended up being just as
important of a thing as all of the games
that you did combined um i think
productivity is another area that's
obviously something that we've
historically been less focused on but i
think it's going to be really important
workroom or give me productivity in the
collaborative app i think that there's
there's a
there's a workrooms aspect of this like
a meeting aspect and then i think that
there's like a
um you know word excel um you know
productivity um
you're like you're working or coding or
what knowledge work right it's as
opposed to just to just meetings so you
can kind of go through all these
different use cases you know gaming i
think we're well on our way social i
think
we're we're just the the kind of
preeminent company that focuses on this
and i think that that's already on quest
becoming
the you know if you look at the list of
what are the top apps um you know social
apps are already you know number one two
three so that's kind of becoming a
critical thing um
but i don't know i would imagine for
someone like you it'll be you know until
we get you know a lot of the work things
dialed in right when this is just like
much more adopted
and
and clearly better than zoom for vc
when you know if you're doing your your
coding or your writing or whatever it is
um in vr which it's not that far off to
imagine that because pretty soon you're
just going to have a screen that's
bigger than you know it'll be your ideal
setup and you can bring it with you and
put it on anywhere and have your your
kind of ideal workstations so
i i think there are a few things to work
out on that but
i don't think that that's more than you
know five years off um and then you'll
get a bunch of other things that like
aren't even
possible or you don't even think about
using a phone or pc for today like
fitness right so i mean i know
you're um
we were talking before about how you're
you're into running and like i'm really
into a lot of things around fitness as
well um you know different things in
different places i got really into
hydrofoiling recently and nice um i saw
video yeah and surfing and um
and i used to fence competitively i like
run so and you were saying that you were
thinking about trying different martial
arts and i tried to trick you and
convince you into doing brazilian jiu
jitsu or you actually mentioned that
that was one you're curious about and
is that a trick yeah i don't know
we're in the metaverse now yeah i think
i mean i took that seriously i thought
that was a that was a real uh
uh
suggestion
that would be an amazing chance if we
ever step on the mat together and just
like roll around i'll show you some
moves well give me a year to train and
and then and then like you know you've
seen rocky iv where the russian faces
off the america i'm the russian in this
picture and then you you're the rocky
the underdog that gets to to win the
idea of me as rocky and like fighting is
um
if he dies he dies
i mean anyway yeah but i mean a lot of
aspects of fitness
you know i don't know if you've
if you've tried supernatural on quest or
so first of all can i just comment on
the fact every time i played around with
quest two
i just i get giddy every time i step
into virtual reality so you mentioned
productivity all those kinds of things
that's definitely
something i'm excited about but really i
just love
the possibilities of stepping into that
world it's it's uh maybe it's the
introvert in me but it just feels like
the most convenient way to travel
into worlds into worlds that are similar
to the real world or totally different
it's like alice in wonderland just try
out crazy stuff the possibilities are
endless and i just i personally
am
just
love
get excited for uh stepping in those
virtual worlds i'm so i'm a huge fan in
terms of the uh
the productivity as a program i spent
most of my day programming that's that's
really interesting also but then you
have to develop the right ideas you have
to develop yeah like the there has to be
a threshold where a large amount of the
programming community moves there
but the collaborative aspects that are
possible
in terms of meetings in terms of the uh
when when two coders are working
together
uh i mean that the possibilities they're
super super exciting
i think that
in building this
we sort of need to balance
there are going to be some new things
that you just couldn't do before and
those are going to be the amazing
experiences so teleporting to any place
right whether it's a real place or
something that people made um
and i mean some of the experiences
around how we can build stuff in new
ways where you know
a lot of the stuff that you know when
i'm coding stuff it's a cart you code it
and then you build it and then you see
it afterwards but increasingly it's
gonna be possible to you know you're in
a world and you're building the world as
you were in it and kind of manipulating
it you know one of the things that we
showed at our inside the lab um
for recent artificial intelligence
progress is this builder bot program
where now you are you can just talk to
it and say hey okay i'm in this world
like put put some trees over there and
it'll do that and like all right put put
some bottles of water on um you know on
on our picnic blanket and it'll do that
and you're in the world and it's i think
they're gonna be new paradigms for
coding so yeah they're to be some things
that i think are just
pretty amazing especially the first few
times that you do them that you're like
whoa like i've never had an experience
like this
but
most of your life
i would imagine is not doing things that
are amazing for the first time
a lot of this in terms of i mean just
answering your question from before
around what is it going to take before
you're spending most of your time in
this well
first of all
let me just say it as an aside the goal
isn't to have people spend a lot more
time in computing i'm asking myself
when will i spend all of my time in it's
to me yeah it's to make computing more
more natural but yes um
but i think it'll you will you will
spend more most of your computing time
in this
when it does the things that you use
computing for somewhat better so you
know maybe
having your perfect workstation is a
five percent improvement on your coding
productivity it maybe it's not like a
you know completely new new thing um but
i mean look if if i could increase the
productivity of every engineer at meta
by five percent um
you know we'd buy those devices for
everyone and i i imagine you know a lot
of other companies would too and that's
how you start getting to the scale that
that i think you know makes this rival
some of the bigger computing platforms
that exist today
you